k-pop sensation bts taking over las
vegas as the first of four sold-out
concerts starts tomorrow night and fans
are already flocking to allegiant
stadium to grab swag before the big
night christian casadas joining us and
uh christian first of all i hope you got
some number one and i guess they're just
gonna light it up like dynamite huh
all right heather it's gonna be smooth
like butter and they're gonna pull you
in like no other that's according to the
bts fan base which are known as bts army
checking out thousands thousands of fans
lining up around allegiant stadium just
to pick up official bts merchandise and
check this out over here on the other
side that that tent all the way in the
back that is where i'm told they're
selling the official official hard to
get pieces like hoodies and even a las
vegas pin that's what some of the fans
are telling me now the shop opened at 10
o'clock this morning but fans have been
in line before sunrise now i spoke to
melody lee last week as the k-pop group
was arriving to las vegas for the
grammys she says their performance on
sunday really just energized the fan
base she was able to grab tickets to all
four sold out shows at allegion stadium
but she's not alone most fans bragging
about the same packed schedule which
also includes themed events off and on
the strip
um honestly i got like two hours of
sleep last night because
yeah we came around like 2 30 in the
morning before this merch so
it's been kind of wild
all right back out here live most fans
telling us they spend on average of
about a thousand dollars on merchandise
not including hotel airfare and food
during their stay here in las vegas so
the economic impact will be significant
after the four day concert stretch wraps
up i'm told also several marquis on the
las vegas strip will be lighting up with
the color purple the official color of
the group just to welcome some of their
fans here to las vegas but of course as
you can see just tons of excitement here
in las vegas but later on this afternoon
i will tell you more about the busy
schedule these fans have as the bts army
continues to sweep las vegas chris
gossett is live local now
wow i mean it's amazing it's like the
beatles of 2022.
las vegas is welcoming bts with a
citywide marquee takeover from eight to
nine tonight christian was talking about
this the marquis are going to light up
welcoming bts some even illuminating in
purple and the fountains of the bellagio
will be launching a fountain show
dedicated to the band at eight o'clock
fountains will be dancing to the tune of
dynamite and butter and they'll run on
heavy rotation this weekend and next
weekend bts also paid a visit to the
famous resort for a sneak peek of the
show earlier
this week so those are photos from
them out there enjoying our beautiful
city welcome guys